hey good morning
have a seat
you are jury number 42 is that correct
yes all right
uh before i turn it over to the
attorneys for questioning there are a
couple things we have to do a couple
questions i have
uh first i'm going to swear you in so
that all your answers are under oath so
if you could just raise your right hand
do you swear or affirm under penalty of
perjury that you will truthfully answer
all questions about your qualifications
to serve as a juror yes
all right um i'm just gonna check
your mic level here
and if you could that's usually a pretty
good uh
distance we are uh using covet
precautions so we have plexiglass
between us and plex glass between you
and the attorneys
and they have their own plexiglas in
front of them
i'm going to continue to wear my mask
since i am the closest one to you
however if you think it would be easier
for you to speak
and if you feel comfortable doing so you
can take the mask off for this part of
the examination
uh just so you know that well first of
all thank you for filling out that
questionnaire
it was greatly appreciated because it
gives us a lot of information
and you clearly spent a lot of time on
it because there's a lot of information
that is valuable to us
uh but first of all everything is true
on the questionnaire
all right is there any changes or
additions to the questionnaire that you
would like to put in
no okay and it's been months i know and
so
when the attorneys start asking you
questions they might
on a reflection think yeah i did have
something to change about that or
add to that it's all appropriate don't
worry about oh i'm saying something
different no it makes sense
uh some of the opinions you uh gave may
have evolved so
it's natural foragers to change what
might be in their questionnaire so
don't be concerned if that's the case
and the attorneys are going to walk
through probably some of the
answers that you gave so um
just kind of think if there's anything
that or change uh you weren't supposed
to read any articles
pay any attention any media but since it
has been several months since you filled
out the questionnaire
have you inadvertently been exposed to
any media you see a headline
or maybe a friend talks to you about
what they read in the paper
uh giving you more information than uh
than you want
i've seen headlines but i've not read
anything okay and as far as the
headlines
do you recall the substance of the
headlines um
i recall saying something about the
other officers
i don't even remember what it was at
this point okay
so nothing about the substance of it or
no
like any court decisions or anything
about the parties personnel pre-trial
stuff
no okay and we ask all these questions
for a very important reason and that i'm
sure you've already guessed
is as a juror you have to decide this
case just on the evidence
follow the law as i give it to you
and you have some knowledge about the
case beforehand
you uh and that's what the questionnaire
tells us
but at the same time and it might also
give you some opinions that you hold
the same time you have to as a juror put
those aside
and decide this case just on the
evidence which
some people say i just can't do it i
can't unsee what i've seen
i i'm just not the type of person who
can do that
it's not a character flaw it's just
we're all different some people can put
it aside
some can they can kind of
compartmentalize that
uh and put it aside and just decide on
what they hear
in the courtroom where do you fall in
that do you think you could do that
um as well as anyone else can i believe
so okay
um and you know yourself better than we
do and
and so we're looking just for an honest
answer uh if you think you could do that
great
um in fact the trains might press you
for a more definitive answer
can you do that or yeah okay um
you recognize any witnesses on that list
you were given
i knew one name but i don't even think
it was a very generic name so i don't
think it's the same person but i just
marked one due to the fact that i
recognized the name
and what's the name if you recall joel
martinez um
uh i'm not sure what the uh full of that
person is
let's say it is that person that you
know is it a close friendship or
no friend of a friend okay more of a
friend of a friend
okay in that case um if you realize that
it is the same person that you know
are you still able to treat that person
like any other witness
apply the same standards that i gave you
yesterday that you'll hear again if
you're on the jury
put them on equal footing yes okay
now we did indicate in the questionnaire
that trial would be approximately four
weeks long
starting march 29th as we've already
seen this morning sometimes there are
delays
but we think that's a pretty good guess
that will start on march 29th
and go for four weeks does that work for
you or better yet can you make it work
yes okay any questions you would have
for me
before i turn you over to the attorneys
okay that's one last uh
piece of advice we have a reporter
taking down everything
we say and so it's much easier if
we not talk over each other
jury selection process can be somewhat
conversational
and so like in a normal conversation you
finish each other's sentences you
interject with the
affirmations or that type of thing uh if
we could try and
not do that not talk over each other and
i will tell you that
the lawyers and i are the worst of them
so
we tend to be the big offenders but we
ask that you also try
not to talk over each other if possible
and to make sure the record's clear
if you could answer yes or no as opposed
to
because the court reporter needs to have
a good record well the court needs a
good record
okay do you have any questions no all
right as the juror number 42 mr nelson
you may inquire
morning ma'am morning thank you for your
patience i know you were here yesterday
for a while
and back this morning with a little bit
of a delay so thank you very much for
being here
i am going to ask you a series of
questions that are kind of general in
their nature first
and then i'm going to follow up with
some specifics on your questionnaire
again we all understand that it's been a
couple months since you've read this and
nobody's trying to trick you or anything
of that nature okay
is that a yes yes yeah okay sorry
i may say that from time to time i'm not
trying to be rude it's just again to get
the record correct
all right okay thanks um so first of all
uh let me assume or let's assume you and
i were to meet under
different circumstances at a party or
some sort of an event
um what are a few things you would want
me to know about you
from that conversation
i am
a genuine person i look for true
friendships
[Music]
do you have any interests hobbies i
like to play hockey hike outside
um cook
wonderful did you play hockey in school
when you were in school
yes okay
now um can you think of in your personal
life
whether it be in a professional context
or in a familial context or even within
your friends
uh your friend group where you've been
called upon to
resolve a conflict between two people
yes
um without giving us any major details
about that conflict
how did you go about like trying to
resolve that conflict
one specific one i'm thinking one was of
was between two people and i just tried
to be a mediator in that situation
and help them talk it through okay
now you understand that if you were to
be selected as a juror on this
uh case you would be in a room with 11
other people
and some conflict about things may come
up
yes you would exp would you expect that
to happen yes
would you um how would you approach that
situation
if you were in the jury room and two
different jurors
had a conflict over some piece of
information
what would you do
i would listen to both sides and again
try to
hear what both people are saying and i
mean that situation
in the office i would have to also say
my thoughts as well
okay and that's kind of where i was
going to go next is
rather than it being two different
people what if it were just you
and one of the other jurors who were in
conflict over a
the importance of a particular piece of
evidence
i would be able to give my thoughts as
well okay and
are you willing to re-examine your
thoughts yes
are you willing to listen to the other
jurors opinion yes
and what if what if it's a situation
where
there's a whole bunch of jurors that are
kind of saying
you're wrong how do what do you do
i would think of a different way to go
about what i was thinking
and express it in maybe a different
manner maybe they weren't understanding
exactly what i was saying
okay but you would you simply just give
up for the sake of
agreement no um
now can you think of a situation in your
personal life where
you've been called upon to try to
determine who's telling the truth
between two sides of the story
not necessarily that i can think of okay
right off the bat
so part of what your job as a juror is
and the court read this instruction
yesterday is to assess the credibility
of particular witnesses in the case
how do you how do you think you would go
about assessing the credibility of a
particular witness
in this case it would be whatever is in
the courtroom
and what is brought forward about that
witness
okay being we have no prior knowledge of
who they are
okay um so
in a situation where let's say two
witnesses
were watching the same set of
circumstances
right it's a car accident and
witness number one says the light was
green and witness number two
says the light was red right that's
assessing the credibility of each
witness
would you agree with that yes okay so
in that circumstance you've got two
people standing right next to each other
or very close to each other
watching the same incident how do you go
about
determining which of those two people is
telling the truth
i think it's important to see what else
is brought to the table
such as what other evidence other
witnesses that were there
timing okay all of those things are
very reasonable right so you would
recognize that there are tools you could
bring to the table to try to
uh assess the credibility things other
than what they're saying
right yes now let's take a for example
if you have a piece of evidence that
is um pretty clear
right i mean you can whether it be a
videotape or a fingerprint or whatever
the case may be whatever piece of
evidence it is
but it speaks for itself right
but two people or two witnesses are
saying something different about that
same thing
how do you assess the credibility there
when it's fingerprints or video um
i think that would be more
valid than what someone is saying okay
but if two people are telling you how to
interpret that piece of evidence
right the meaning of the evidence
in other words and they have differing
opinions as to the meaning of that
evidence
how do you assess that again i think you
have to look at other
things other than just opinions and that
video would be other things that come
into play
in that situation okay good
um in your personal life can you think
or
again professional familial whatever can
you think of a situation where you've
been 100
convinced of something and then it later
turns out you're wrong
no okay can you imagine that happening
in life
yes um
let's let's again take a hypothetical if
you were
um certainly convinced of something
right you had formed an opinion it was a
strong opinion
and it later turns out you were wrong
how would you
how would you anticipate reacting to
something like that
admitting to my wrong okay um
and how do you how do you apply that
later in life
maybe evaluate situations more deeply or
okay
so one of the rules of law that will
apply
in this case is that the judge will
instruct you on the law if you were to
be a juror in this case
right could you
follow the law even if you thought it
was
wrong or you disagreed with it yes
so you could read the law judge the
facts of the case
and um apply the law even if you thought
that
that the law should be changed yes now
in terms of
um in terms of
your role as a prospective juror it is
to be
[Music]
a finder of the facts is what we call
what you're the judge of the facts you
you would be one of 12 people deciding
what happened
do you understand that yes and you
understand that ultimately it would be
require a unanimous jury verdict to
either convict
or acquit mr show do you understand that
yes
and if you were um if you were
to be to find yourself on either side of
the situation the odd man out so
to speak or the odd person out i guess i
should say um
a woman how would you
would you be the type of person that
would dig your heels in
and say i'm not changing my opinion no
matter what or
would you be the person that would
simply
concede to get this over with rather
than
continue fighting
i am the type of person to hold my
ground so i guess it depends on where
we're at and where everyone is at in the
situation
but i'm not afraid to stand up when
others are against me
okay so i'm gonna turn again
now to your questionnaire and
ask you some follow-up questions again
it's we recognize it's been
i guess two at least two months since
you filled it out
so um the first question
that you're asked was um to ask
about what you had heard or what you
sort of knew about this case
do you recall um that question generally
yes
all right and so what you wrote is you
wrote a
about a page of information that you had
learned from the news
right the balloon from the news or
conversations or things of that nature
yes
um do you watch the news or regularly
read the news
not anymore well obviously but at this
point
did you yes okay at the point you filled
out your questionnaire you did
right yes all right um
one of the things that you wrote was
about
um remembering that there were two
autopsies performed
in the case yes that's what you believed
that had happened
yes now one of the things
that is very important is
only certain evidence is going to come
into the courtroom
and that's what you're required to judge
the case on right but if you have
some knowledge from the time before
you filled this out and that information
is not presented in this courtroom
um are you able to kind of set aside
what you may have
remembered or may have learned before
and focus only on what's in the
courtroom
yes
you were asked um to to
um state your opinions
as to both uh mr chauvin
as well as mr floyd do you remember
those questions generally yes and
in terms of your opinion as to mr
chauvin
you indicated that it was a somewhat
negative response
yes okay and you wrote the only reason i
chose this
and not neutral is due to the fact that
it went on
so long the knee in parentheticals
so can you just explain how why did that
influence your opinion to the more
negative
of mr show i saw well i could only watch
part of the video and
from what i saw as a human i
that did not give me a good impression
okay and it's important for you to
understand that
you are entitled to have your opinions
right you as a human being are entitled
to have your opinions
and we may or may not disagree on
whatever some of your opinions
are you appreciate that yes
and nobody is asking you to set aside
your personal
opinions or beliefs here uh generally
speaking do you understand that
yes however the concern is is that your
personal opinions seep into or affect
your decision-making process as a jury
do you understand why we would be
concerned about that
yes both from the defense as well as
from the state of minnesota do you
understand that
yes okay um and
we have to take what you tell us at face
value
you understand that yes we don't know
what you're
really thinking or what's in your heart
and that's why
and it's okay for you to embrace your
own personal opinions
okay
so the fact that you formed that opinion
and that opinion was negative to some
degree because of what you saw on the
video
and we'll talk about the video in a
second but because of what you saw on
the video
you just thought that it was from as a
human being
that it was hard to watch yes and that
it was
um longer than it needed to be
yes and that you felt that the
defendant made a decision about how to
treat this person that was
inhumane yes
now the video that we're talking about i
want to make sure because there are lots
of videos that have
been released into the public sphere and
the video i want to make sure we're
talking about is there was a bystander
video
and that bystander video got uploaded to
facebook
it went viral and the media started
paying attention
is that the video you refer to i guess
i'm not quite sure
but most likely okay there are other
videos that
have been released publicly like
surveillance videos from
nearby stores and there are some
body-worn cameras that may have been out
in
from the police officers that may be in
the public sphere
do you can you tell you recall from what
perspective you were watching this video
was it would it have been from a
bystander
from a police officer or a security
system high standard
okay so we're probably talking about the
same video
did you first come across that video on
social media or did you see it in the
news
social media and when you saw it
um you indicated that you had watched it
one time
although i do not think i fully or
finished it fully is what you said
um so did were you watching sort of
through social media that
that native uh longer form video
yes and then on the me in the news
right there were um like
little clips from that video that you
may have seen
possibly or still frame images taken
from that video
possibly okay um but
why do you think it is that you didn't
fully finish it
i just couldn't watch it anymore because
you found it to be and you may
correct yes and again
you know you have um
you have a certain set of life
experiences
right would you agree with me that
you're not a police officer
yes would you agree with me that you've
never been trained
in the uh arrest of an individual
yes and that there may be information
well let me ask it this way would you be
willing to let other information
about police procedure what happens
before or
after all of these things potentially
affect
your decision would you allow your
decision to be
changed if you gathered more information
what decision i haven't made a decision
yet no i mean your opinion i apologize
yes okay so you would be willing to keep
an open mind
hear all of the evidence right yes
you you testify or i keep saying
testified you
told me earlier uh that um
when you were called upon to resolve
this conflict from
between your two friends or colleagues
that you it was important that you
listen to both sides
yes can you do that here yes
you were um asked in the questionnaire
about whether you
talked about george floyd's death with
friends and family members
and you wrote and what opinions you may
have expressed
and you wrote confusion confusion
sadness for everyone
and the need for possible police reform
can you explain that a little bit more
yeah i mean conversation happened a lot
in the news with friends family
i think for most people and i think when
there wasn't an
answer we didn't know what was going on
and everyone saw the video and what's
going on the news
there was just a lot of confusion as to
why
okay what do you mean by the need for
possible police reform
just that just that it it could be or
may not be we need
please reform right i mean
are you open to the possibility that
police reform is
not needed no
um so you do believe that there are some
reforms that are
needed to be made as a result of this
incident yes
again and that's perfectly okay i'm not
you know
um you indicated that you had uh in fact
yourself participated in a peaceful blm
protest in duluth and you did not carry
a sign
yes and that other people um
other people like your cousins uh i
believe
indicated that they had also
participated in some marches they were
in minneapolis yes
okay um why did you decide to go to that
protest
i just felt it was necessary to show my
support
okay um your support for whom
others who have been affected by similar
situations
okay so not simply this particular case
in this case so again
you have a an opinion about
this case you have an opinion about
mr chauvin you have an opinion about
the need for police reform and all of
those opinions are your
you are entitled to those opinions can
you honestly tell us that you can set
aside those
strong opinions and judge this case
on the facts alone yes
now during the questionnaire you were
also
asked some questions that were there
were more statements
and you were asked to judge your or rank
your
um agreement on them on a scale
of one to five do you recall that
generally
i don't remember what the statements
were right but you remember like a
circling one or two or three yeah a list
of
various statements so i want to ask you
some follow-up questions on some of
those
so um the first question
reads discrimination is not
as bad as the media makes it out to be
you circled four that you somewhat
disagreed with that
and you wrote what media what did you
mean
first and foremost by the statement what
media and
why would you just somewhat disagree
with that statement
um i mean every news station has a
different
view on it or you see different things
on every news station whether it's
the actual news or it's instagram or
it's facebook you just see a wide
variety of things so i don't think
there's a
general media that you can talk about
okay
and why would you disagree with the
statement discrimination is not as bad
as the media makes it
because i guess i just didn't know what
media was being talking about okay
that's fair enough um
he asked acts the question
or the statement reads blacks and other
minorities do not receive
equal treatment as whites in the
criminal justice system
and you checked somewhat agree why did
you check somewhat agree to that scene
um
just with everything that was shown in
the world this past year
that's just what i believe at this point
okay not
pointing to any personal experience or
any sort of
quantitative data you're just saying i
kind of agree with that
um i have friends who have been
mistreated by the police too and only
people of color
okay um
okay the question was presented i
support defunding
the minneapolis police department and
you indicated that you had no
opinion of that but you wrote would need
more research but cannot
until after trial can you just i mean
again
i understand that once you filled this
questionnaire out you didn't go
start researching but you have no
opinion
why because i don't know exactly what it
means at this point
but as i mentioned before i do believe
in police reform okay
the statement reads because law
enforcement officers have such
dangerous jobs it is not right to
second-guess
decisions they make while on duty and
you strongly disagreed with that
proposition
why um
[Music]
even police officers are human and
humans make mistakes
okay do you think that there are
different
levels of police decision-making
yes do you think there are circumstances
where
a police officer may have time to think
through his or her decision
formulate a plan and then execute that
plan
yes and then there would be certain
circumstances where an officer
would have to make a very quick decision
right
yes um and sometimes under incredible
stress or
danger to themselves or others would you
agree with that yes
do you think that there is a distinction
between those two types of decisions
yes do you think one is more fair to
question than the other
not necessarily okay so
where is is there any distinction so you
would say any decision that a police
officer
makes is should be
questioned yes
you indicated that your
mother's uncle used to be a police
officer
so your great uncle was a police officer
yes how well did you know him
or did you know him i see him probably
once or twice a year
okay has he ever was he a police officer
here in the city or
elsewhere you don't need to tell us
where but out state not in minneapolis
in the state of minnesota yes okay
if you were to um well let me ask you
did he ever like kind of tell you
stories about his career or anything
like that
yes okay um
if you were to be a juror on this case
and if a question of police policy or
practice came up
would you take it upon yourself to call
your great uncle and ask him questions
about
what's right what's wrong no okay just
have to ask
you also indicated that your your cousin
is a nurse
if this case involved medical testimony
would you um call your cousin and ask
for her opinion as to the medical
no
so i i skipped one question that i've
been asking other jurors
at the beginning kind of a general
question
when you uh it's my understanding of the
process is that you received
just a like a page or two letter that
tells you that you have jury duty
and then a little bit later you received
a packet of information
and this questionnaire and then you
received instructions
maybe later from there right does that
sound like the process as you recall it
yes so when you got that first letter
that told you that you had been
summonsed for jury duty
what was your initial reaction i was
surprised
why were you surprised
it's a global case everyone got involved
and
honestly i thought older people would be
picked okay even though that might not
be a thing
so i mean i'm talking about just sort of
that initial letter before you knew what
was for this case
or did you know in that first letter you
were being called we knew in the first
letter
okay all right that i believe because
some people are describing that they
figured it out when they got this
packet it doesn't matter so
your response was when you especially
when you learned that it was this case
it was surprised because it was a global
case and you figured that older people
would be called
um as opposed to someone who's in her
early adulthood
yeah i just thought why me okay and
ultimately then in the questionnaire
it's the questionnaire asks do you want
to serve as a juror in this case and you
check the box yes
and they when asking why it says i am i
am a recent college grad
i know it sounds cheesy but i believe
everything happens for a reason
i believe that where i am in life there
is a reason i have been called to be
here
this case has been global news and it
will take a special someone to be able
to put
everything aside and be present at the
trial
right you remember writing that so i
just have a
so do you feel that that you are serving
some higher purpose by being involved in
this
case what do you mean by higher purpose
well you know there are some people who
desperately want to get off of a jury
right and so they'll say just about
anything they can say
to not have to be on a jury service and
then there are some people
who really really want to be on the jury
for whatever reason that may be and so
they'll say pretty much anything
they think they have to do to say to get
on to the jury
right and i'm just curious because you
reference that you're
you know that you're here for some
special reason what would that reason be
would it be to make sure that mr chauvin
is convicted
no what would the reason be
have someone here that has an open mind
and who is able to be here for the right
reason
and i'm just answering these questions
honestly and if i'm chosen
then that's the way it's supposed to be
but if i'm not then
that's the way it's supposed to be okay
fair enough
may i have a moment your honor
you are excused from this panel uh
you're also excused from your jury
service
for this term so unless you get a
summons
in the years to come you're free to go
about your business
thank you though for taking the time to
fill this out we appreciate it
i have that as defense number eight is
that correct
uh we're going to probably take a
15-minute break i don't know if we have
our
juror and even if we do they have to go
through the
15-minute orientation video uh that is
standard
so it'll be at least 15 minutes so let's
circle back at 10 o'clock to see if
we're ready to go because the juror who
is missing
who's up on their way is our next
juror so let's be in recess at least
until 10 o'clock
thank you
all right just for the record we are
back on both audio and
video
and we are getting the other jurors for
the group instructions
you
all right you can pick any seat you wish
it's just like church everybody takes
the back row that's okay
uh we want you to be comfortable in this
process
well good morning everyone first of all
can you all hear me
if not we have hearing assistance
devices and everyone is nodding yes
my name is pete cahill and i'm one of
the judges of the district court
you have been summoned as potential
jurors in the case of state of minnesota
versus derek chovan
which is a criminal case related to the
death of george floyd on may 25th
2020 a person charged with a crime has a
right to a fair trial before an
impartial judge and an impartial jury
in order to make sure the jurors who are
selected are impartial
the law provides that the court and the
attorneys for the parties
may ask all questions or may ask
questions to all prospective jurors
which must be answered under oath first
of all thank you for filling out and
sending back the questionnaire that we
sent you that's a great help to us
in knowing a little bit about your
background
your contribution to the important and
serious matter at hand
is best served by your continuing to
answer those questions
fully completely and honestly the
questions that you'll hear today will
follow up on issues from the
questionnaire
and possibly other topics after the
questioning is over the attorneys may
excuse you
from service on this jury and i may
excuse you for what's called cause
in either case it does not mean that you
are not a fair and impartial person
and you should not take offense in being
excused
i also ask that you not take any offense
any questions that are asked
to some extent you must pry in order to
explore opinions you might hold and to
talk about some experiences that you
have had
that might affect your ability to serve
in this case
the defendant mr chauvin has been
charged with murder in the second degree
and manslaughter in the second degree
but in the normal course of trial
charges are likely to be added or
subtracted
but those are the charges for you to
consider today when you are hearing the
questions
to the charges the defendant has entered
a plea of not guilty which is a denial
of
each and every material allegation in
the charges
and now i'm going to ask the different
attorneys and parties to represe
uh to introduce themselves so for the
state
good morning ladies and gentlemen my
name is steve slicher representing the
state of minnesota
good morning my name is christina
maranakis and i'm assisting with the
prosecution
good morning everyone my name is keith
ellison representative minnesota
good morning joshua larson also with the
state of minnesota thank you
mr nelson if you could introduce
yourself and your client
good morning my name is eric nelson this
is my client derek shovin
my assistant amy voss thank you
now in addition to the attorneys from
the attorney general's office who are
here
other attorneys might make their
presence known and be a part of the case
those include aaron eldridge jerry
blackwell
and possibly other and matthew frank
does anyone know
any of those attorneys or anybody who
works for the attorney general's office
okay and you're number 44 i think we'll
deal with that when you uh
come forward for your individual
question remind us that uh
you have to tell us about the specifics
anyone know anyone from mr nelson's firm
or have any assault
with them okay everyone's shaking their
heads no
anyone acquainted with anyone else in
the courtroom
as you look around no one familiar all
right
now you have been given a copy of a list
of potential witnesses
during your individual examination
you'll be asked if you know anybody on
that list and the nature of the
relationship
so keep that in mind and also bring that
list with you
when you come into the courtroom later
on
now one of the things the attorneys may
not do in jury selection
is to instruct you on the law but i do
want you to be aware of some of the
basic concepts that apply in all
criminal cases
so that you may keep them in mind as you
answer the courts and the attorney's
questions
so i will instruct you as follows first
the charges against the defendant are
not evidence and they create no
inference of guilt
no member of the jury should in any way
permit himself or herself to be
prejudiced against the defendant
because a charge has been made against
him or because he has been placed on
trial
the defendant is presumed innocent of
the charges made against him
and in order for you to find the
defendant guilty the state must prove
guilt
beyond a reasonable doubt the defendant
does not have to prove his innocence
the presumption of innocence remains
with the defendant throughout the trial
unless and until he has been proven
guilty beyond a reasonable doubt
according to the law and the evidence
admitted at trial
beyond a reasonable doubt is such proof
as ordinarily prudent men and women
would act upon
in their most important affairs a
reasonable doubt is a doubt based upon
reason
and common sense it does not mean a
fanciful or capricious doubt
nor does it mean beyond all possibility
of doubt
now if you serve on this jury you and
your fellow jurors will be the sole
judges
of whether a witness is to be believed
and of the weight to be given their
testimony
they're no hard and fast rules to guide
you in this respect
but in determining believability and
weight of testimony you may take into
consideration the witnesses interest
or lack of interest in the outcome of
the case the relationship
to the parties their ability and
opportunity to know
remember and relate the facts their
manner
their age and experience their frankness
and sincerity or the lack thereof
reasonableness or the unreasonableness
of their testimony
in light of all the other evidence in
the case
also any other factors that bear
unbelievability and weight
if i'm this jury you should rely on the
last analysis
upon your own experience
you are not to use the internet to look
for information about this case
or about the law above all you must not
talk to anyone who is involved
lawyers witnesses or spectators do not
be offended if the attorneys parties or
witnesses do not speak to you
they know that it would be improper to
contact you through the normal
except through the normal selection
process and so the attorneys
and parties will confine themselves to a
brief greeting
during the selection process your family
and friends will be curious as to what
you are doing
and you may tell them that you are on a
panel potential jurors in a criminal
case
and that is all you should tell them
since that is all you should tell family
and friends
that is all you should tell the general
public so during these proceedings
please refrain from using facebook
twitter or other social media
to announce that you are a potential
juror or to comment on this trial
you may access those social media tools
but please do not publish any
information about this case
or your thoughts about this case you do
not have to stay away
from people and refuse to speak to them
do whatever you wish but do not talk
about the case
and in particular do not talk at all to
anyone involved in it
because of the nature of the charges
this case is receiving media coverage
do not read about this case in the
newspapers or watch anything online
do not listen to news about it on radio
or television
this trial including jury selection is
being televised
but no video of you
or any juror will be taken at any time
now or during trial if you are selected
also your name will not be used in the
courtroom in order
to protect your privacy you will only be
referred to by your random number
the audio of anything you say will be
broadcast
unless we need to discuss something that
is deeply personal
or extremely sensitive or embarrassing
and i specifically ordered the audio
to not be broadcast in that case you
will still have to answer questions on
the record
but without audio or video broadcast
and with that uh the exception of juror
number 44
i'm gonna direct uh the remaining jurors
to follow the deputy back to the
courtroom you're just
in keeping in mind that we are
exercising coveted
protections so i took my mask off
because we are far away from each other
and so that i could be clear i'm going
to be putting it back on when
you are in the witness stand for jury
selection please while you're in the
courtroom keep your mask on
maintain social distancing and feel free
to use all the hand sanitizers and wipes
that you wish
with that if you could go to the deputy
with the exception of juror number 44.
all right you're 44 if you could come on
up to the witness stand again
and just for the record we had a short
discussion off the record or
off audio and video
and just so we are clear we are
currently on audio only
we are aware that there's some matters
that we are going to discuss
uh with you where we will not only go
off audio but take the extra step
of excluding spectators from the
courtroom so that only the parties
the attorneys and a technician who
controls our audio and video
uh will be present uh just an advisory
there
so uh before i turn it over the attorney
a couple things i want to do is number
one i have to
swear you in to make sure that all your
answers are on your own so if you could
raise your right hand
do you swear or affirm under penalty of
perjury
that you will truthfully answer all
questions about your qualifications to
serve as a juror
nice elsewhere all right well first of
all
uh you filled out a questionnaire thank
you for doing so you took uh
you took great care it appears to fill
it out accurately and we appreciate that
uh is everything true that's on the
questionnaire yes
all right are there any changes or
additions to the questionnaire that you
feel comfortable at this time
uh bringing to our attention just the
one thing that we need to discuss off
audio
right okay and i also appreciate the
fact that you kind of marked it
very well on the questionnaire so we'll
abide by
your request all the parties agree on
that
at some point other than that
the attorneys might ask you a question
that prompts another recollection
or you may realize an opinion you may
have given in the questionnaire has
evolved maybe it's changed
it's just what you know that it is all
right in fact we hope if it's an
honest answer is that you give a
different answer we
don't think anyone is lying to us it's
just that things change
people on reflection realize maybe
there's some stuff they should have
added
so feel free to offer something even if
it is different from what's in your
questionnaire
you were not supposed to read any
articles uh or watch media since you
filled out the questionnaire because the
questionnaire itself gave that advisory
but we recognize it's been a couple
months you may have inadvertently been
exposed to something
a headline maybe a friend talk to you
about the case
and since we told you don't tell anybody
that you're a potential juror you
couldn't exactly stop them
so did anything like that happen to you
that you became of more
aware of more information from when you
fill out the questionnaire
until today and be it a headline about
pre-trial matters the parties
anything about the case no i mean i
tried
i don't watch local news that much and
i haven't turned it on all week
specifically because i knew
this was happening but i last week i
remember
news coverage of you know fences going
up or whatever
precincts and around this building and
stuff but other than that that's been it
all right yeah okay
and the reason why we ask these
questions i'm sure you know
is everybody who's filled out the
questionnaire
knows something about the case various
degrees of knowledge
and i think almost everyone has formed
certain opinions
about the case or the people involved
and the question is whether you can put
all that aside because as a juror you
have to be fair and impartial
partially part of what is being fair and
impartial
is that we are all working off the same
uh knowledge base so in other words
put aside what you've learned outside
the courtroom put aside
your opinions i know you can't put them
on your mind completely but just
not make them part of the analysis
decide the case just on the evidence
that you hear in the courtroom
and base it on the law that i give you
at the end of the case
could you do that absolutely okay
did you recognize any of the witnesses
on that long list no
okay we did indicate the length of the
trial would be about a month
for example if you were picked on this
jury you would
be on your own feel free to do anything
you want until march 29th
and we anticipate starting trial with
opening statements and evidence on that
day
and probably it'll last about this is an
estimate uh
about four weeks can you make that work
with your personal life yes
okay little hesitation there is there a
concern that you wanted to talk about or
i'm a single mom okay got two teenage
boys a senior and sophomore in high
school
okay um they can stay with their dad i
think the first week
is actually spring break for them okay
um and so
they can be with their dad and um
all right you will not be sequestered
during the trial itself um unless
something happens
when i have to order and that would be
my decision right now i don't see any
need for that
so you can go home at the end of the day
we might have some long days
so it might be a little late getting
home but deliberations themselves will
be sequestered you'll be kept together
put up in a hotel until come to a
verdict um
can you make that work yes all right
and we've had other jurors express
similar issues that they are single
parents but
with younger children it sounds like the
teenagers they're kind of capable on
their own it would just be that
sequestered part that i figured during
deliberation we would be
yeah so they could be left on their own
sometimes we hope they make good
decisions with their teenage brains but
you can pretty much my 18 year old is
not staying by himself
uh sounds like you've already thought
through this process either my mom's
there they're going to their nets
it sounds like a good decision uh all
right uh
before i turn it over to the attorneys
anything else
any questions you have for me all right
with that um
before i turn over mr nelson just
another uh advisory is
when we are doing this it can become
conversational
okay and in a typical informal
conversation we'll interject with
affirmations or
even answering the question before it's
finished uh because we need a good
record of this we'd ask that you as much
as you can
try not to talk over each other okay um
and i will acknowledge in saying that
that the lawyers and i are the worst
offenders
so but if you could we could all try and
uh get to that
uh position that would be wonderful uh
with that as to juror number 44
uh mr nelson you may inquire you may
sure
all right i think what we're going to do
is
uh mr nelson will ask you some questions
first but
uh we are going to go right into some of
the more sensitive things
and at everyone's agreement and we are
going to
go off the audio
the video will simply be of the seal and
things like that
not on any of us so there won't be any
lip reading not that they could with
this
but in any case we will go off audio
completely
and we will ask that spectators
all right for the record our spectators
have returned and uh
our we will go back on audio again uh
juror number 44 you are not on any video
whatsoever
uh strictly on audio but it is being
broadcast and so with
that i'm going to turn it back over to
mr nelson for some questioning
oh and by the way if you want you can
also take your mask off it's totally up
to you
i'll keep mine on okay
uh good morning how are you today i'm
well thank you
um thank you again for your time and um
being here and answering questions
i'm sorry for the delays and things of
that nature but
we we definitely appreciate your
participation in this case
so what i'm going to do here moving
forward
is i am going to um ask you a series of
kind of
general broad questions um
just to kind of get to know you a little
bit better and then we're gonna
focus on some of your responses to the
questionnaire you filled out a couple
months ago
is that okay with you yes all right and
again we know that you probably haven't
read or thought about this document in
the last couple of months
if there are specific things i want to
ask you about i will ask you about them
and i'll
tell you what you wrote okay all right
um so let's start with uh this let's
assume you and i met in
under different circumstances at some
social event or party or whatever
um and we were chatting first
introduction what are a couple things i
would walk away knowing about you
i'm a mom okay i
love the outdoors so i'm really active
outdoors and then
you know about my job because in the
nonprofit sector yeah
we we advocate and talk about
our mission-based work great and
again without identifying anything about
who you work for or where you work
um what is the general nature of your
advocacy
uh in your job current job
yes healthcare healthcare okay
and um i believe um i'm going to kind of
skip forward because i just got to get
it out of the way
you've had some contact with mr ellison
in the course of your career
correct um do you know him personally
no do you socialize with him no it's
simply through
a kind of your work as an advocate
correct
and um is there anything about your past
experiences with mr ellison that would
in any way make it
fair or make you a fair or impartial
juror
no okay one possible outcome of this
case would be a not guilty verdict
correct would you um hesitate in your
decision
simply by virtue of the fact that you
may have to go back to mr ellison at
some other time and advocate for your
employer absolutely not okay good
just have to be clear and want to make
sure well
my decision on the case would be based
on the facts
perfect either way so
you know if the facts show that it's not
guilty then
i'm pretty sure that mr ellenson would
understand that
and the reverse right sure at least i
would hope
perfect all right so um
at some point you received a jury
summons and questionnaire
and it became clear that you were a
prospective juror in this particular
case
yes now um what was your initial
reaction to learning that you could be a
juror in this partic
particular case oh my god right
is that was that a good oh my god or a
bad oh my god or
probably more of a terrifying oh my god
okay and because it is such a high
profile case
and so i mean that's kind of a
i've been on a jury before in the past
and
it was nothing like what i probably
would go through on this jury
sure so in that regard um
when you say it was a terrifying kind of
a response
um was it did you have concerns for your
physical or personal safety or the
personal or physical safety of your
children
no i'm not concerned for physical safety
okay are you concerned about like being
harassed or harangued as a result of
your
involvement in this case i think
anyone that said they wouldn't be
concerned with that would be lying
um so of course i'm i'm concerned with
that because i do think
you know you have
people that are very much wanting a
verdict one way or the other
and they may not accept what verdict
comes out
and so i think
there's a very real